I live in New York State one of many
where politicians spend more money than
we have there's a four point four
billion dollar deficit my governor wants
to raise taxes but this man says there's
a better way to raise money we can lease
naming rights on our infrastructure weak
infrastructure meaning bridges tunnels
the Triborough bridge can be called the
staples bridge or the Apple bridge
companies would pay because bridges are
seen by lots of people hundreds of
thousands of vehicles pass by and see
that big sign that's valuable that I'd
disagree with that's a bad idea
most people we ask didn't like the idea
I would I definitely wouldn't want to
rename something after some sort of
corporation people don't like this it's
commercialized absolutely it take your
face and say this doesn't sound good if
you want to and you're gonna wind up in
a place where the tax burden is insanely
high I just think some things should be
left pure and not tainted by money no
she should do start a non-profit raise
thirty million dollars she named it
whatever she wants it's one of the
largest construction projects in the
country our governor just had a
beautiful new bridge built that he named
it after his father yes he did that's
true
Governor Mario Cuomo bridges we actually
have an imperial bridge named after our
royal family I'm embarrassed sharp is
the Libertarian candidate we
libertarians don't worship politicians
and don't think they deserve monuments
just because they got elected I tell you
what I'll do
he's got 30 min hours a year he can keep
his name in that bridge and he's taking
the maintenance someone asked me Larry
how you gonna pay for I 80 won Sharp's
campaign is attracting new people his
rallies have bigger crowds than third
party candidates normally get and sharps
original ideas help get him speaking
roles and big events and media coverage
if you unhappy with the system you got
to change it one poll found sharp
getting 13% and after people here is
campaign pitch 25% supportive I'm not
gonna roll back
some of sharps positions surprisement
your libertarian I assume you want to
cut these wasteful programs of course
not look the issue here is you don't
want to just pull the rug out from
people because when you do that they
become afraid if people are afraid they
rarely vote for you you would keep all
these when did I sell my program yeah
I said no new programs and you would
keep existing sure why who said I'll get
rid of them and I just assumed because
they're inefficient they're bloated so
get rid of them that's the best the
worst idea let me be very clear about
something if you pull the rug out from
somebody somebody is going to be afraid
Sharpe focuses on his alternatives to
taxes why don't we set have a 3m bridge
or an Apple bridge or a Pepsi bridge why
hasn't this been done because no one has
any new ideas there's no ideas how I'm
gonna fix anything or do anything right
does even exist I'm a third party I have
to have ideas or no one will listen to
me the MTA New York subway system is
falling apart trains a packed buses a
packed we need the money so sharp says
read out the tracks at night we have so
many lines in the MTA right now that are
not being used at all at night Home
Depot or Google or Amazon or whomever
they can decide they can use these
freight lines they'll help pay for
maintenance obviously and they'll pay to
move their freight again win-win-win
then Sharpe said something else that
surprised me there are systems out there
that are both safe and unionized so we
keep unions happy and our workers safe
and be cheaper why do you want to keep
the union's happy because they're
unionized why would I want why not
communions happy because unions can be
destructive they can be able to think of
a libertarian as a pro-union guy unions
are part of a First Amendment thing it's
people getting together saying they
won't do X until you do why not that at
all it raises prices fine that's okay it
is what it is collective bargaining is
fine my issue with unis has always been
are you forcing me to be in a union are
you forcing United labor if you're
forcing it I'm a libertarian have a
problem with that but you're voluntarily
doing it Pramod all sharp is the rare
politician who proposes new ideas that
might actually reduce the burden of
government this man liked his subway
funding idea
I think that'll be good we need air
condition in the subway so Amazon get us
air condition he's thinking the right
way
Amazon I love it will love it I like
that guy and I like it that there's at
least one candidate who doesn't want to
make government bigger new programs
no I'm libertarian no no no no no no no
no take care of people you know what
party I'm part of right libertarians
believe that you should be as
conservative or as liberal as you want
to be as long as you don't want to force
yourself on others Larry Sharpe for
governor 2018 thank you very much